[Musique]
oui mais ma parole aux actes antisémites
sa mort lundi puis cette semaine via son
je veux parler avec vous d'une nouvelle
que l'on peut voir tenir les médias dans
les médias sociaux
la sortie de la commission de laurent
qui justement a étudié le rapport et les
relations entre la dpj et les
communautés autochtones des fois même
l'absence de ces relations et a mis de
l'avant des recommandations
préliminaires puisque le rapport final
va sortir en avril 2010 il recommande
fortement de laisser justement les
communautés pouvoir et les nations pour
partir une relation un système service
qui est beaucoup plus adapté avec les
besoins de chaque nation faut pas
oublier qu on a vu dernièrement les
modèles du québec qui ont eux mêmes qui
en changent leurs modèles de dpj les i
nous demande la même chose
pourquoi est ce que c'est si important
de vouloir faire un modèle autochtone à
ce point là s'il faut pas oublier que
pendant très longtemps les services dpj
où les services familiales ont été
utilisés même les x instrumentalisé par
l'état pour pouvoir continuer ce qu'il
avait dit à monsec les les pensionnaires
c'est à dire l'art offre des années 60
où beaucoup d'enfants ont été placés
dans des familles d'accueil pour pour
détruire le lien entre la famille
d'origine la culture et continuer cette
espèce de mentalité de tuer les aider et
sauver l'enfant
on voit les avaient pas qu'aujourd'hui
on peut voir les statistiques il ya plus
de huit fois la surreprésentation des
jeunes autochtones dans les milieux de
la dpj que d autres nations alors il ya
une problématique c'est pas normal qu'il
ya eu 4 % de la population est cinq à
huit pour cent de ses enfants dans un
système qui lui représente 8 fautes plus
qu'à ceux qui sont plus nombreux dans le
restant de la pressez vous comprendrez
que c'est normal c'est pas parce que les
communautés autochtones n'aiment pas
leurs enfants ou sont des moins bons
parents non c'est un système qui est
écrit et qui offre facilité justement
cette institutionnalisation des enfants
et la relation est extrêmement difficile
puisque souvent que la barrière de la
langue la barrière culturelle
les distorsions cognitives qu'on peut
avoir aussi envers les parents
autochtone viennent faire en sorte
souvent le bouton facile pour placer des
enfants autochtones
d'ailleurs faut pas oublier que
certaines de ces problématiques ne ont
emmené des drames
je pense particulièrement à la dpj de
juliette qui présentement sous enquête
avec la cdp des jcc quand même dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de problématiques et
là on a vu aussi sur les médias sociaux
dernièrement à chaque match a lieu deux
hommes des enfants qui étaient placés
dans les familles c'est à dire chez les
grands-parents ichi l'attendent mais qui
ont jugé inadéquat
alors que c'était considéré comme très
adéquat et qui ont été pris par
justement la dpj mais cependant ça a été
filmé sur les médias sociaux
ils sont ça permet de faire ressentir
justement la situation est juste
l'impuissance que des fois on peut vivre
face à ces situations là il mais
malheureusement c'est tout sur les
médias sociaux c'est ainsi qu'on peut
créer cette relation de de voir et de
ressentir je commence que les
autochtones de différentes nations viva
vous partout à travers le canada
donc il faut comprendre que ces
recommandations ne vont être regardé
attentivement faut comprendre aussi que
qu'on parle de racisme systémique c'est
à dire que les problèmes de racisme à
travers le système ils ont été créés à
la loi sur des uns étaient donc on a pu
voir les pensionnats on a pu voir la
robe des années 60 on peut voir comme le
système aujourd'hui est biaisé par
rapport à toute la compréhension
culturelle parce que des fois c'est
parce que la personne parle pognon gagny
france elle ne peut pas être le gardien
où j'ai même entendu des fois que des
services avec des applis parce que le
parent n'était de l'enfant dans un
porte-bébé traditionnel alors que c'est
la poussette qui existe chez les pros
nations depuis des milliers d'années et
ça avait été vu que tu vraiment quelque
chose d'atroce comme s'ils ont maltraité
l'enfant beaucoup d'autres histoires par
le passage d'une par exemple
on vient au monde les enfants entrent
comme souvent avec une tache de
naissance qui s'appelle la tâche
mongoloïde c'est un bien qu'on peut
reconnecter avec l'asie mais c'est une
tache bleue qui ressemble vraiment le
coup qui aurait été donné dès fois dans
le bas du dos mais on peut en avoir
aussi sur les doigts et ça c'était
souvent ignorés comme étant une tache de
naissance culturellement représenta
digne parce que nous l'avons aussi c'est
quoi mais c'est vu comme une
maltraitance est plutôt que dans le cas
tu es là dessus on prenait les enfants
et on les place et donc beaucoup d'enjeu
beaucoup pratiquent beaucoup d'ignorance
mais aussi beaucoup de solutions qui
sont apportées par les communautés qui
vont écouter et qui vont être mis de
l'avant
ces prochains mois alors n'hésitez pas à
envoyer des questions et je dois
partager ses vidéos il était surtout pas
vous avez formé sur la commission
laurent qui va sortir bientôt